Speaker 1: . Let's stick with the phones, by which
I mean discord David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Extraordinarily powerful phone calls happening
today, and we don't want to miss a minute of it.
Let's go to Bobby from Jersey. Bobby from
George, Jersey, welcome. What's going on?
Bobby from Jersey. You've got to unmute yourself.
Speaker 2: Hello? David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All right. Is there a specific
way that you go about engaging with conspiracy?
Speaker 1: Depends on the specifics, I would say.
I mean, it depends on where and with whom.
Speaker 2: Sort of, like I say, far right
conspiracies like and on and like the election
results or whatnot. Yeah. Like, is there really
a way you can, like, debunk that or.
Speaker 1: I mean, the problem is that
a lot of the people that believe this stuff
aren't actually open to thinking of thinking
critically about it. And so if you show them
contradictory evidence, they say that evidence
is not reliable or has been planted. If you show
them the absence of evidence for what they say,
they go right because they're covering up the
evidence for what I believe. So unfortunately,
with a lot of them, there's really no way to talk
them out of it or even get them to reconsider.
Speaker 2: Yeah. That's what I
noticed, too. Hi, David. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you very much.
There's Bobby from Jersey. Yeah. I mean,
unfortunately, it's. It's depressing
is the reality. It's depressing.